bonjour à toutes et à tous j'espère que
vous êtes très content
je suis vraiment vraiment
comme erwan le disais je suis
le temps et notamment des conférences ce
que je donne sur un autre sujet et c'est
vrai que faire un tête basse et c'est un
peu le niveau niveau au-dessus quoi donc
c'est vraiment c'est vraiment énorme
pour moi surtout que quand ils ont
commencé à chercher des spicules ils ont
cherché des experts et comme l'a dit
juan moi je suis voilà je suis expert en
bâtiment pour le compte des assurances
si vous avez un signe chez vous ce que
j'espère parce que ça va me donner du
travail et bien votre assurance
potentiellement va envoyer un expert je
vais venir je fais un rapport et vous
aurez pas d'argent voilà mais c'est pas
tout ça que j'ai envie de vous parler
j'ai envie de partager avec vous une
expérience qui m'est arrivé quand
j'étais à votre place en fait donc
plutôt vers la fin j'étais à la fin de
mes études apolit et que comme une
dizaine en énergie bâtiment
environnement et puis l'administration
au corps enseignant et décide
d'organiser une petite réunion pour vous
expliquer ce qui va se passer après
parce qu'effectivement passer un diplôme
dans le but d'avoir un travail qui nous
plaisent et donc on se regroupe et on
parle de l'entretien embauche du cv
genre de choses et pour nous aider dans
notre démarche de recherche d'emploi
il met toute une liste de l'entreprise
d'un qu'elles sont allées les anciens
étudiants alors on retrouve les acteurs
principale du bâtiment et de l'énergie
un statistiquement donc bouygues eiffage
vinci edf angie etc
et puis on a un professeur garde cette
liste et il se dit je comprends pas
pourquoi ya pas totale c'est vrai ils
font de l'énergie et puis doit bien
construire des bâtiments de temps en
temps alors tout le monde se regarde
parce que l'intitulé de la formation ces
énergies bâtiment et environnement
alors je pas si vous connaissez total
disons que il exploite du pétrole
utilisé dans les moteurs c'est
principalement responsables des
gaz à effet de serre d'émissions de gaz
à effet de serre et puis bah issus de la
petite rolls pétrochimie en arts
plastiques sont générateurs et en
pollution on entend beaucoup parler en
ce moment dans l'est les mers les océans
donc niveau environnement se pose là
quoi je veux dire c'est pas la tête de
la conférence est donc
donc il nous dit ça je comprends pas
pourquoi ya pas totale et moi je hasarde
une question dont je dis monsieur est ce
que vous pouvez pas concevoir qu'on
puisse avoir des problèmes moraux à
postuler chez total alors que le recul
parce qu'il est toujours plus facile de
juger avec le recul il ya plein de
réponses qu aurait pu m'être fait du
style est ce que tu t'es vraiment
renseigné sur total c'est quand même un
fleuron de l'industrie française
multinationales est ce que est ce que tu
es sûr que ses rangs le monstre que tu
as l'air de décrire ou alors quelque
chose du style un peu à la gandhi sur le
changement que tu veux voir dans le
monde rentre à total et puis change
total ou alors même je crois que
j'aurais préféré un truc du style
non mais t'as vu ton bulletin ils vont
jamais de prendre quoi alors à fassi
assieds-toi un veuvage aux sables à la
question monsieur vous pensez pas qu'on
puisse avoir des réticences morales à
l'etrat et chez total la réponse qui m'a
été fait c'est en même temps si tu veut
pas bosser je peux rien faire pour toi
alors qu'ils se rassurent depuis que je
suis diplômé j'ai pas arrêté de bosser
même que je suis cadre alors je compte
pas mes heures
des fois quand j'ai envie de m'arrêter à
21h ou 22h j'ai le choix je fais ce que
je n'étais pas c'est vraiment ça le sens
de ma question en fait mais j'en parle
parce que pour moi c'est assez
révélateur si vous voulez dans un sens
imaginer que je puisse être dans une
société où avoir des valeurs et des
convictions une morale ça puisse être un
frein sur le marché de l' embauche sur
marché de l'emploi al embauche ça me
fait dire que c'est pas une bonne
société finalement moi j'aurais envie
qu'en donnent les meilleurs jeunes aux
meilleures personnes aux gens que dont
on peut communément admettre qu'ils sont
sont des bonnes personnes et on en vient
à l'autre domaine d expertise donc ce
qui est le sujet de cette conf de ce
talk qui est qui a trait finalement la
quête de sens alors qu'est ce que c'est
que la quête de sens je vous proposais
une définition pour moi déjà c'est un
processus c'est quelque chose qui se
passe sur le temps long donc comme tout
processus ça démarre à un endroit pour
moi ça démarre quand on se rend compte
que nos choix nos choix de consommation
nos choix de loisirs nos choix de
mobilité d'énergie nos choix travail ont
un impact sur notre environnement proche
et puis de proche en proche surtout
notre toute notre société typiquement si
je vais au supermarché
j'ai envie d'acheter des oeufs si je
prends la boîte de gauche ou si je
prends un boîte de droite
l'impact sur mon environnement proche et
pas énorme sauf que la boîte de gauche
c'est marqué dessus les poules elles
elles vont en plein air elles ont une
vie assez longue
elles sont nourries au bon grain de
l'agriculteur d'à côté et puis la boîte
de droite et ben c'est marqué dessus
aussi
elles sont élevées dans des cages
et toute leur vie elles vont passer dans
dans une cage qui a la taille grosso
modo d'une feuille a4 donc finalement de
faire ça ou de faire ça ça n'a pas eu un
grand impact
et pourtant le choix que vient de faire
raconte ce que j'ai envie de voir dans
ma société
quand on prend conscience de ça eh ben
c'est là que commence la quête de sens
la quête de sens quelque part c'est
quelque chose qu'on subit aussi un petit
peu et qui nous pousse à nous sentir
responsable alors ça c'est dur comme si
comme si individuellement on était
responsable de la société
c'est énorme alors bon on peut se peut
se rassurer en se disant que si on est
tous individuellement responsables de la
société alors la responsabilité s dilue
entre nous tous
et puis à tel point que quand on en
aurait presque plus mais ce que je
voudrais vous proposer c'est une autre
vision de ce mot responsable responsable
ça partagent une étymologie avec
répondre qu'est ce que ça veut dire être
responsable c'est avoir envie de
répondre de ses actes ok quand on pose
la question mais pourquoi tu as fait ça
parce que bîmes question à faire et vous
ne pouvez pas répondre à cette question
si ce que vous faites pour vous ça n'a
pas de sens voilà ce que c'est la quête
de sens c'est un processus d'auto
responsabilisation et quand on a 10 à 20
finalement c'est quelque chose de très
positif je vois pas comment ça pourrait
être négative de sentir responsable et
de vouloir faire en sorte que notre
société sur la meilleure possible et
pourtant on a des gens comme ce
professeur
en fait la question que lui posait en
somme c'est est ce que vous me proposez
est ce que ce que vous me proposez ça a
du sens il m'a dit ben en gros voilà tu
es un feignant gpat répondre j'ai pas à
parler de sens avec toi à ce moment là
ce que vous avez compris c'est que il a
un peu perdu de l'autorité autorités
aussi étymologiquement c'est très
intéressant ça veut dire augmenter là il
m'a pas augmenté donc il a perdu son
autorité
pour donc ouais la quête de sens
finalement c'est quelque chose si vous
sentez en vous parce que je vous dis en
général on le subit si vous le sentez en
vous sachez que pendant toute votre vie
et surtout au travail ça va vous être
contestées donc ce que je voulais aussi
aujourd'hui c'est vous donner des
petites clés des petites choses pour
vous puissiez vivre une bonne quête de
sens quête de sens pour moi ça ça
commence par deux piliers déjà connaître
l'environnement
et puis se connaître soi même comme ça
quand on connaît tous ben voilà on est
plus plus outils connaître
l'environnement pourquoi
imaginons vous lisez un article à un
moment donné et puis vous a plu un
article qui parle de coca par coca cola
je sais pas si vous connaissez coca cola
et donc vous apprenez que coca cola
il pratique la prédation illégitime des
ressources le travail des enfants se
fait partie des acteurs les principales
la production de plastique dans le monde
c'est l'hégémonie américaine un discours
un peu ambigu sur leur responsabilité
dans l'eau puis dans l'obésité de leurs
clients et vous lisez ça et vous dit à
mes plus jamais je vois du cocasse une
marque affreuse et vous allez à la
distributeurs de boissons et puis vous
dit à vos copains très fier voilà moi je
boycotte coca donc je vais prendre un
chouette sauf quelque chose en fait
c'est distribué par coca ça prenait sa
bomba je prends un fanta l'a annoncé par
est innocent jus de fruits innocent a
aussi distribué par coca ok voilà il
faut connaître l'environnement parce que
sinon vous pouvez effectivement avoir
des choix de consommation que c'est pas
tout à fait éclairé qui correspondent
pas tout à fait aux valeurs mais sa
limite je pense que vous le faites un
surtout aujourd'hui où l'information est
hyper accessible par contre il ya un
autre truc que vous
souvent on fait pas alors je sais qu'ils
le font à côté a lieu parce que j'avais
des cours là bas avec quand on en a
parlé c'est c'est apprendre à se
connaître soi même des fois vous allez à
des entretiens d'embauché
et puis vous avez un rh du siècle
d'avant qui vous dit donnez moi trois
qualités et trois défauts
alors je vais faire quelque chose pour
vous qui est pas facile pour moi mais
comme j'ai travaillé ça va bien se
passer
c'est tellement difficile que vous
pourrez applaudir après ça vous n'êtes
pas obligé je vous donnais si qualité à
moi ok donc moi je suis gentil généreux
fidèles puis cérébrale je suis sensible
et je suis courageux personne
n'applaudit hockey et je vous dis pas ça
pour me la péter pour m'envoyer des
fleurs je vous dis ça parce que si un
jour je rentre dans une entreprise et
qu'on me demande de me couper
complètement en empathie des gens à qui
je travaille dans une compétition
acharnée où je dois enfoncé tout le
monde si on me demande de pas du tout
réfléchir à ce que je fais mais vraiment
d'agir comme une machine et ben non
seulement je vais être nul mais en plus
quand je vais être bon ben je vais pas
te fier de moi parce que c'est pas en
phase avec mes valeurs à ce moment là
qu'est ce qui peut se passer
on commence par irritabilité manque de
sommeil
on dort mal et puis et puis de fil en
aiguille si on s'acharne dans cette voie
on peut aller jusqu'au burn out
bon comme vous avez fait cette conf
aujourd'hui à aucun de vous qui fera un
bain homme dans sa vie
j'ai les noms mais d'après une étude du
figaro publiée en 2016 parmi les
français interrogés un tiers avait fait
un burn-out scam et non bon je pense pas
qu'à chaque fois ce soit le gros burn
out mais quand même prenez soin de vous
prenez soin de vous d'ailleurs ça fait
partie des trois conseils que je
voudrais vous donner pour bien vivre
votre quête de sens prenez soin de vous
si vous faites un burn-out votre manager
peut-être qu'il va pas se dire à mr jeu
les poussait à bout j'aurai peut-être
pas dû peut-être qu'il fasse du rhin le
faible quand je veux faire pour le
remplacer mois
et vous seriez me abbou vraiment pour
cette personne mais ça n'a aucun sens a
fait pas ça quand vous voyez que ça se
passe mal écoutez vous demandez vous si
c'est pas le moment pour vous de prendre
un autre chemin
mais en même temps prenez soin de vous
mais travailler travailler dur travail
et à devenir la meilleure version de
vous-même travailler à donner du sens à
ce que vous faites ne travaillez pas
avoir un diplôme travailler à donner du
sens à vos diplômes ne travaille pas
avoir un job travail à donner du sens à
ce que travailler dur pour vous et pour
les autres travaillez prenez soin de
vous et entourez vous des bonnes
personnes ça c'est enfin ça paraît
évident mais je veux dire
ce même manager ce professeur dont je
parlais au début voilà c'est des gens à
un moment donné quand on les rencontre
et qu'on voit que on partage pas les
mêmes valeurs
ça veut pas dire que c'est une mauvaise
personne ça veut dire qu'on est sur un
chemin et qu'on partage pas le même
chemin et qu'on a besoin véritablement
de faire nos chemins chacun de notre
côté
ok on arrive à la fin de ce thème
donc un petit résumé la quête de sens
pour moi c'est un processus d'auto
responsabilise d'auto responsabilisation
qui passe par la conscience que vous
avez un impact sur notre société et qu'à
chaque fois qu'on vous demande pourquoi
vous avez fait ça vous avez envie de
dire parce que à ce moment là vous
chercher du sens vous cherchez vers
l'extérieur et vers l'intérieur
important et puis évidemment vous prenez
soin de vous vous travaillez dieu à vous
entourer des bonnes personnes
en faisant ce ted je me suis je vais
m'amuser jusqu'au bout et pour finir je
vous donnais une citation une citation
qui me suit depuis un moment qui a une
grande chance pour moi et je prends la
responsabilité
c'est une citation de dominique venner
le monde le monde les amis
ne sera pas sauvée par les les savants
aveugle ou les érudits blasé le monde
sera sauvé par les poètes et les
guerriers qui refonde rond l'épée
magique qui fait pâlir les tyrans et les
monstres le monde sera sauvé par les
veilleurs procès postés aux frontières
des royaumes et du temps merci
[Applaudissements]
à